It's been a long
time.Have you forgotten the look on the face of someone who saved your life?
Unfortunately, I haven't felt my life in danger in the last 10 years
.
[Music]
This was very
helpful
, so I hope you will remember me as a disciple of life for the rest of your life.
It
's the ideal to open a vague introduction by eating grass in a vacant manner, but
you shouldn't underestimate Yagi, who gives you a strange sense of vitality
.  The goat has standard Japanese horns It
's like a demon It's
not that easy Our company
[Music]
I bought the one that the wind fell in love at first sight Ah, even at that time, that girl wasn't wearing a beret, but you're an assistant You can
identify it with a hat  I'm sorry I'm not good at remembering girls' faces, and if I
remembered too much, Saki-san got in a bad mood
, so please remember again.
My child has turned 17.
Life is good.
I
won't forget this time.